[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voix mais on a le droit de dire
publiquement qu'on ne veut pas participé
aux [ __ ] hqe la sueur de répondre
favorablement à l'invitation l'année
prochaine c'est vrai que depuis le
départ de jean jacques goldman les
grosses stars se font de plus en plus
rares au sein de la troupe je ne savais
pas si je retrouve encore l'esprit de
coluche voilà tout simplement pourtant
derrière ce show se trouve une oeuvre
caritative importante lancée par coluche
les restos du coeur et qui vient en aide
aux personnes démunies s'ils sont
nombreux à avoir refusé de participer au
programme comme gims julien doré ou
stromae récemment c'est francis cabrel
qui s'est exprimé dans le parisien en
évoquant son retrait définitif de la
bande j'ai l'âge d'être traité des
[ __ ] revenir maintenant je me
sentirai moins en phase l'idéal serait
de laisser la place aux jeunes des
jeunes qui peinent à rejoindre
l'émission qui s'essouffle un peu plus
d'année en année alors les [ __ ] une
star peut-elle vraiment dire
publiquement qu'elles refusent d'y
participer
après trente ans au sein de la troupe
catherine lara nous explique pourquoi
elle a décidé de ne plus en faire partie
[Musique]
merci catherine d'être là alors
catherine tu ne veux plus participent
aux enfants et je te tue trois jeunes
moi je suis pas venu faire le procès
indien sur la raison en fait je suis
resté presque trente ans j'ai commencé
en 1985 j'étais là au premier concert y
avait trois pelés et deux tondus il y
avait une ou sur scène et c'était un
moment assez extraordinaire moi j'ai eu
la chance surtout de vivre une époque où
il y avait des vraies duos des trios des
quatuors on avait le temps de chanter ou
faisait pas une phrase et au sort ou
deux phrases et au sort moi j'ai adoré
cette époque là j'ai des souvenirs
mémorables de maurane céline dion faire
des duos on pleurait on était tous sens
je manque un peu de chair de poule dans
l'histoire ou à la masse qui manque
c'est un peu un peu de plus d'émotions
et bien sûr et je dis je regrette cette
époque là voilà trinel parle du
spectacle voilà
la cause on va encore bien sûr
participer pour aider les restos du
coeur encore cette année et c'est vrai
que les enfants rient ça reste quand
même un énorme carton d'audience ans
bien sûr mais c'est formidable que ça
existe directement c'est un des
spectacles voilà anne marcassus fait un
travail fabuleux et que mathieu verne
voilà c'est important de le dire aussi
mais ces briquets des artistes qui n'ont
pas envie d'y participer et moi ce qui
me gêne c'est que certains les blâmes
alors que chacun fait ce qui lui plaît
voyez pas que ces artistes là ne donne
pas pour les restaurateurs ou ne font
pas pour d'autres causes sont des
artistes qui juste ne semble pas dans le
spectacle dans les déguisements dans
peut-être les sketches dans les
conditions qui y a et c'est juste ça et
c'est vrai qu'ils s'en prennent plein la
gueule parce qu'ils le disent et je
trouve ça un petit peu regrettable kelly
moi je pense que l'industrie du de la
musicale a changé il ya tout il va plus
vite il ya beaucoup d'artistes qui sont
des stars pendant une année qui ne le
sont plus le grain et d'après et moi je
pense que c'est difficile pour les
anciens de s'y retrouver justement dans
ce milieu là après on ne peut pas du
tout les blâmer je ne comprends pas les
personnes teamteam blâme ces artistes
parce que dans le sens où on ne connaît
pas leur vie on sait pas ce qu'ils font
en dehors de ce spectacle et tous les
nouveaux qu'ils le font je pense qu'ils
font de taff et ils le font avec le
coeur mais faut pas oublier que ce sont
quand même des artistes est un artiste
mais en fait il se force pas à faire les
choses il faut qu'il le fasse avec le
coeur s'il faut que ce soit bien fait
alors guillaume genton pas déjà c'est
pas parce qu'une star ne participe pas
aux enfants et qu'elle participe à aucun
projet caritatif ya plein de stars qui
le font cela se voyait et puis il faut
dire la vérité les [ __ ] c'est très
chronophage c'est une semaine de
concerts c'est beaucoup de répétitions
dont je peux comprendre que aussi des
artistes qu'ils soient pas disponibles
et c'est pas parce qu'ils n'adhèrent pas
aux [ __ ] qu'il faut les blâmer pour
autant alors vous vous trouvez un
problème de génération si trop de trop
dans les [ __ ] que vous retrouvez pas
les néo moi je moi je dis pas place aux
jeunes parce que je suis persuadé que
les aînés les téléspectateurs ont envie
de voir les vieux schnock comme nous ils
sont derrière nos intentions de terry
ils sont ils sont heureux d'entendre
francis d'entendre jean jacques et les
autres moi un moment donné je me suis
dit bon le large c'est déjà en soi un
déguisement donc ça peut être un peu
double emploi déjà se dédia c'est encore
ça va très bien magnifique vous êtes un
danger le départ de de jean jacques
goldman aussi ça peut-être aussi fait
que voilà il ya plein de gens c'est
qu'ils sont ni je vais partir avec lui
aussi enfin je veux plus revenir il a
moins c'est plus difficile de dire non à
jean jacques goldman il ya quelqu'un
dont federer voilà c'est ça quand jean
jacques goldman vous appelle pour faire
les [ __ ] compliqué de l'unité l'âme
des [ __ ] jean-jacques ouais c'est ça
c'est de l'amener [ __ ] après michel
quand coluche est parti c'est jean
jacques qui a pris le relais c'était
évidemment c'est reese et maryse et
autres ya une anecdote que
ça va peut-être que vous savez si c'est
vrai ou pas c'est que jean jacques
goldman tenais tellement aux [ __ ]
vous savez il avait fait l'album de
johnny
d abord de johnny qui a été un énorme
succès et john il avait frappé pour
refaire un album avec lui et jean
jacques goldman à part et il n'avait pas
rappelé parce que johnny avait refusé
n'était plus dans les [ __ ] et pour
lui c'était très important qu'il soit
dans les [ __ ] c'est vrai que jean
jacques goldman voilà c est y voit là il
s'est dit voilà c'est vrai que je veux
qu'il soit dans les enfants et johnny et
il avait refusé je crois d'écrire un
deuxième album pour lui parce qu'il
avait refusé d'être dans les [ __ ]
c'est vrai mais je crois bien que c'est
vrai est d'autant plus que effectivement
comme valérie il souligné il était
fédérateur jean jacques goldman c'était
le boss est effectivement il ne
supportait pas c'était le chef et sam en
ces lieux qu organiser tous qui
prévoyait tout avec anne marcassus qui
va chanter quoi et que ses chances y
après tati les parties jean-jacques ça a
été un peu une petite guerre entre chefs
et ça ça a créé des petits soucis or il
faut pas aussi il ya un truc aussi
qu'ils disent et que tous les artistes
certains artistes se tirent la bourre
c'est ça voilà que c'est compliqué moi
j'ai dix minutes sur scène toi ton à 15
soit en avant moi je suis passé avant
toi et c'est vrai que ça aussi c'est ce
qui est mana qui veulent pas rentrer
dans ces guerres d'ego aussi il y en a
plein qui disent oui moi j'ai pas envie
moi j'ai envie de faire mon métier j'ai
pas envie d'être en compétition avec
d'autres artistes surtout pour cette
cause là valérie bas c'est là que ça me
chagrine moi je pense qu'on peut
effectivement dire je ne veux pas y
participer parce que je ne me retrouve
pas et et ça m'ennuie parce que j'ai pas
envie de me déguiser ou parce que voilà
ici c'est plus mon univers oui voilà et
ça je peux l'entendre tout à fait la
seule chose qui me chagrine en revanche
c'est quand on n'attaque entre
guillemets le spectacle en lui-même
parce que j'ai peur que ça ne
rejaillisse sur la cause et il faut
toujours se dire attention dans ma prise
de parole quand je vais expliquer pour
quelle raison je n'y vais pas de faire
attention à le dire sans abîmer sans
écorner les [ __ ] parce qu'il ya une
cause importante voilà c'est c'est
toujours moi à chaque fois je tremble
toujours quand quelqu'un dit j'y vais
pas parce que j'ai toujours peur que
derrière il y ait moins de ventes de
disques will moins de ventes de cd parce
que derrière watchguard et c'est pour ça
que moi je réponds oui à la question
peut-on blâmer oui et j'ai évolué là
dessus parce qu'aujourd'hui la situation
est trop grave et chaque artiste qui n'y
va pas qui dit publiquement qu'il n'y va
pas ça va faire que par exemple à la
billetterie qui ouvre demain les gens
vont paître hésité à prendre leur billet
pour le prochain spectacle à montpellier
ou après mais tu ne sais pas mais n'en
peut plus normal c'est le cd donc moi je
dis aujourd'hui que la responsabilité de
tous les artistes sollicités elle est
d'y aller même si à des rivales ans et
même si je viens d'y aller
battus de moi je veux juste un tout
petit peu à jean jacques goldman parce
que je trouve que vos paroles un peu
attention commun qui a tout fait
évidemment non mais je finis ma phrase
juste un cloud c'est sur son départ il
est parti il a décidé de partir mais
c'est vrai qu'il aurait dû préparer un
petit peu là près il n'ya pas eu d'après
et depuis qu'il est parti effectivement
il ya plein d'artistes qui tout d'un
coup aux dires qui veut plus aller ce
n'était pas le cas avant et puis c'est
vrai que depuis qu'il est parti il n'y a
pas de chef et partout il faut un chef
malgré tout et on sait pas du tout du
coup on sait plus très bien
effectivement il n'ya plus vraiment de
duos effectivement comme yavé moral j'ai
dû refaire on sait plus trop si c'est
l'humour il ya un peu trop de comics il
on sait plus trop ce qu'on regarde il
aurait dû préparer son après me revoilà
maintenant c'est untel c'est untel il
faut des artistes comme vous des
artistes qui ont un certain voilà
certains passé et on sait plus
aujourd'hui qu'il bosse et où qu'on soit
il faut un chef ici c'est vous l'air
dans les coulisses c'est vrai que oui il
ya des infos oui mais sur les guerres
dans les coulisses oui moi où tu vois il
ya très longtemps déjà quand on assister
aux répétitions nom des sentiments il ya
une bataille d'ego moi je pense plus
album pourquoi l'huile est sur le devant
de la scène plus que moi en revanche
noir on cite pas le travail de michael
youn c'est pas un chef mais il est un
des joyaux est en revanche bien
évidemment qu'on a le droit de blâmer
évidemment qu'on à droite pas se sentir
à l'aise et ce que dit catherine lara
est très important dans les derniers
étude qualitative le spectacle était
formidable mais les gens ont trouvé
qu'on perdait un peu le côté spectacle
et le côté duos trios et que maintenant
il y avait un peu une espèce un petit
peu fourre tout qui l'est moins qu'ils
aient mon instinct j'avais l'impression
qu'on faisait d'un grand concert et
maintenant c'est un divertissement elle
savait qu'un footballeur avec un avec un
comique avec c'est autre chose quoi
c'est devenu mais c'est vrai que nous
serions dans laquelle il ou à l'aise et
qu'il faut être là au bon pour pour
aussi pour défendre la production c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui on se dit plus on
veut toucher de monde l on doit les
taper dans voilà dans des footballeurs
qui sont très aimé des 17 / tu en voilà
et c'est donc c'est vrai qu'on y laisser
de taper un petit peu partout et on peut
comprendre ce qu'ils east plomb va avoir
deux stars et plus revoir de gens qui
aimeraient dans les [ __ ] plus les
gens vont avoir envie d'acheter le
disque est peut-être de 2 voilà de
soutenir la cause et c'est ça aussi
après c'est un a toujours vendu du
disque un sachet vrai ça ne marchera
toujours ça parce que c'est quand même
on pensait que faut privilégier sur
belgique quelque part comme la nuit
oui c'est pour moi
si j'adore j'adore plaisait
on est encore en fait qu'ils sont avec
l'eau du bain parce qu
on est en train de trouver des défauts
au spectacle faut quand même rappeler ça
cartonne chaque année ça fait 8 9
millions téléspectateurs ça te fait
plaisir ça reste un énorme succès il ya
un chef ou par an chez les enfants et
c'est un carton c'est pas comme si des
liens non mais c'est pas comme si les
audiences et avait divisé par deux
depuis que jean jacques goldman n'est
plus la maquiller
géraldine maillet non mais
malheureusement c'est un spectacle
formidable parce qu'effectivement il ya
encore des gens qui crèvent de cela on a
encore besoin malheureusement
malheureusement donc mais en revanche
moi je suis un peu d'accord avec valérie
je trouve que les égos des uns et des
autres en fait moi je m'en fous il
importe peu de savoir qui à des
chamailleries parce que dans toute
famille recomposée finalement il ya des
jeunes et des vieux ya des moments qui
allait moins bien que non mais là ça me
dérange pas mais je trouve que vous
votre position est extrêmement digne
comme celle de francis cabrel d'ailleurs
qui dézingue absolument pas la cause
mais dès qu'il est juste pas dû la
menace aux jeunes en ligne sur centraux
206 + dans ce spectacle voilà et de la
rue pierre palmade detroit une nouvelle
génération de nouveaux montants
absolument pas d'y retourner ou pas
aussi bon pourquoi pas je dirais moi je
veux j'ai que des copains là bas j'ai
bien sûr j léger les c30 tant d'amis
qu'il adorerait que vous retourniez
voilà vous faites un nuit magique
franchement avec toute une aile à oui
mais alors je me disant moi même ce que
je suis avec vous et vous pour laver
cette année on se déguise et ce n'est
pas possible et sans vous déguiser à
wissant se déguiser oui juste pour un
mois le déguisement maintenant je suis
le real le dirait que j'ai plus ridicule
que le déguisement
vivement il ya trop de happening comme
ça aujourd'hui
oui mais bon c'est toutes ces petites
choses là qui me dérange un peu moi j'ai
vraiment connu une époque divine quoi ça
fait un peu vieux combattant mais non
vieux con cours d'eau
et c'est vrai que je me sens comme vous
avez envie d'y retourner mais moi j'aime
la musique j'aime partager moi j'ai vécu
des j'ai fait des trios des quatuors
avec goldman cabrel souchon et bien
j'ai des souvenirs inoubliables quoi
grave et donc moi je vais arriver un
beau quatuor comme ça sur nuit magique
avec catherine et tout ça serait pas mal
oui on peut le faire si vous voulez me
fait tout faire moi je vous ai dit je
suis pas venu faire un procès je vous ai
dit moi c'est affectif voilà j'ai je
manque un peu de chair de poule voilà
c'est le rêve plutôt serré parce que
c'est une sensation un paisible à
seissan forêt non non non alors d'autres
artistes voilà comme catherine catherine
voilà j'aimerais en tout cas j'ai un
break catherine jégat surtout s'il vous
plaît on cherche des grosses têtes dont
les footballeurs dans les chanteurs dans
les artistes et pourquoi benjamin vient
de me dire que les animateurs n'avait
pas le droit c'est comme ça c'est la
règle lui permettre d'aller les restos
et que mon grand père est un principe et
aux plats mais j'irai ce qu'il a fait
mais je ricane jane au caire et un seul
mais c'est vrai qu'au départ il y avait
tout le monde des abeilles bricaire il y
avait voilà et après il ya eu une espèce
de consensus ont aidé on ne met plus
d'animateurs et je pense que c'est pour
des questions des croûtes des uns et des
autres oui et le rôle est d'aider des
pas mais pour répondre à la question
parce que ce qui me ce qui me dérange un
peu c'est que j'ai remarqué depuis 4 5
ans est de bon ton d'aller critiqué les
[ __ ] je vous le dis on ne peut pas
critiquer les [ __ ] quelques sous
quels que soient les coulisses que si
c'est être pas quelle que soit voilà
qu'elle se soit les choses un peu tu
revenir derrière et oui j'ai des
artistes ils ont ils ont un égo et wiba
y en a un petit peu raide devant
derrière c'est franchement ça n'a pas
d'intérêt et on devrait arrêter de
parler au taux de fret pour les
mauvaises raisons la seule bonne raison
c'est qu'on peut ne pas y aller parce
qu'on n'a pas envie d'y aller absolument
soutenir c'est hyper important
dispositif c'est des dizaines des
centaines alors pas il ya quelqu'un qui
me dit à l'ats à la fin merci
et il ya jean jacques goldman qui leur
disaient aussi paraît qu'à l'époque
jacques goldman ou d'idées il faut venir
tous les jours et être là tout le temps
au répète etc si vous voulez pas venir
tous les jours c'est pas la peine de
venir faire la captation sur tf1 et
c'est vrai que c'est ça aussi peut-être
qu'à mener oui mais cette cohésion vécu
j'ai vu des oueds et des mômes qui
venait simplement le samedi et le
dimanche gras seissannais toute la
semaine puis venaient faire ou télé on
n'est pas là pour faire une telle à ce
que disait jean la nouvelle c6 nourrir
des gens qui crèvent de faim quoi si
vous êtes la fin une télé c'est pas la
peine de venir vous pouvez retourner
chez vous mais voilà c'est pas les
missions qu'ils préfèrent oui oui mais
le médoc au label accord effectivement
des captations parfois se faisait sur
différents soir donc c'était vraiment
beaucoup de travail c'est les gens
savent pas forcément que ça passe sur
tf1 met donc on aura bien pardon est ce
que j'ai tout eu valeur effectivement
oui il faut un boss qui de temps en
temps dit voilà il faut faire ça c'est
sur plusieurs jours il faut répéter il
faut venir si la personne qui a ce
pouvoir pour faire ça mais c'est pareil
partout bloqué l'une fait ça par exemple
est un ami quel cépage avait demandé à
peut-être
se permettrait pas le pauvre il s'est
déjà fait déjà beaucoup de travail où il
écrit les textes ils essaient de faire
des sketchs et c'est à michael je
connais c'est pas un mec qui va se
permettre de dire aux gens que tu vas
bien s'effacer pas son rôle le pot il va
pas se mettre en porte à faux avec des
artistes et leur dire tu vas être là
toute l'année les séries la doua été
désigné leader des [ __ ] il a pris le
truc pour que le spectacle soit beau et
c'est bien je vais écrire des sketches
et je vais idées pour être les sketchs
le spectacle soit de drôle et passant le
spectacle de qualité mais pauvre il va
pas dire je vais appeler les artistes et
leurs biens en mai théâtre la scène et
12 jean jacques goldman c'est lui le
chef est-ce que c'est lui qui a créé
truc donc forcément tout le monde
l'écouté là aujourd'hui c'est compliqué
c'est vrai de darna retient surtout la
perte de deux des gens comme cabrel des
gens comme catherine lara effectivement
des gens qui sont respectés totalement
voilà qui sont qui sont adoubés ne parle
pas leur métier justement il faut
quelqu'un youn que j'adore ne peut pas
effectivement devenir adhérent non mais
c'est pas ça qui le guette s'est passé
ailleurs il ne demande pas moins jusqu'à
pour faire un an pour écrire des
sketches pour faire un beau spectacle
mais c'est vrai que c'est combien je
reviens que c'est lui qui a créé le truc
donc ils auraient fort est quelqu'un qui
soit là depuis le des magnats trina la
mise la prime devrait dans mes choix
mais
il faudrait voilà et je pense est vrai
que jean-jacques c'était vraiment
larmes de cette histoire c'est ça
choisissez les chansons il faisait des
choix merveilleux et lââm sens musical
la wii extraordinaire il faisait les
duos et mettait les bonnes personnes
ensemble et c'est tout un art de faire
ça c'est pas sa fraîcheur tout seul j'ai
aimé ce que je me demande à passer des
heures jean-jacques ses heures des
oeuvres plus surtout dans tous les
articles vidéos il vous a vu ce que vous
avez cités tout à l'heure vous avez dit
quand même on faisait des duos avec s'il
vous rendez vous des quatuors des
tribunes on est content ou pas catherine
lara maurane céline dion plateau déjà tu
veux faire c'est vrai que c'est
incroyable wifi le vernet sauf que je
trouve que mathieu est un peu dur avec
michaël youn très franchement pourquoi
nommer michael n'a pas du tout été du
rallye ont raconté lundi qu'il manquait
un chef mais alors mais elle n'est pas
sûre il a raison les mixer la poursuite
fc et l'as edelman s'il n'est pas là si
on le demande à mickael peut-être qu'il
le fera mais la pensée non mais c'est
l'artistique aurait bien c'est quoi la
part et je suis fière mais non mais s'il
n'était pas là oui des histoires qu'on a
n'a pas justement il n'y a pas
d'histoire jeudi
que sa part mme ebale silva sachant s'il
n'était pas là s'ils n'étaient pas là
c'est le ciment peut-être que c'est pas
le chef mais c'est le cimetière
n'étaient pas là aujourd'hui je me
demande même si les [ __ ]
continuerait que se réunir en aussi
grand nombre il évoquait des faits non
mais franchement le lien social et la
manque un peu de collectif le lien
social c'est lui honnêtement l'afrique
devrait lui rendre hommage
marc a su qui vient très bien ce matin
et mathieu et robert goldman le frère de
jean jacques ils ont tous vécu ça ils
sont là depuis le départ aussi et croyez
moi que ça marche très très bien moi
j'ai assisté souvent alors il est vrai
qu'à michael youn qui travaille super
bien pas mais pas d'aussi obispo aussi à
une époque quand ils venaient matin
pascal non plus aujourd'hui c'est une
nouvelle qui serait le leader naturel
antoinette cplc bruel qui serait
aujourd'hui est ce que c'est ce qui se
dit mais bien sûr bien sûr qu'après oui
papa mais des prêts mais il est là
n'était point de vue il connaît le
fonctionnement de l'histoire et ça ils
aiment les restos il aime le il aime il
aime cette histoire c'est vrai
cela est normal de renouveler aussi
parfois les chanteurs parfois on
critique l'émission
c'est dommage on voit plus untel et
untel mais par exemple est et à
l'arrivée de vianne et il ya tous ces
gens là il ya d'ailleurs une traînée
viany
diffèrent mais tu fais une connerie mais
dit il ne fait plus mièvre la cité
quatre personnes et la catho rennais
avait les clés mais ce n'est pas fair
nous témoigne pernikoff prend la place
de passer non mais c'est sur écoute que
j'en ai marre mais sans rigoler mais
arrêté de dire une bêtise d'idées mais
alors mais via n'aimez pas la clim est
attendu le 18 qui participent et tais
toi qui lis que les conneries c'est pas
continuer plus les autres ennemis
rangeant devant catherine
merci je voulais remercier notamment le
sondage voir ce que pensent les
téléspectateurs oui à l'offre et voilà
voilà vous voyez au pardon